tommy's so nervous about you guys coming
in
you never let anything on to us yeah you
heard that right even superheroes get
nervous around their heroes he was so
nervous and cause like you know he's
like i don't want to step on anyone's
toes zendaya exposes her boy tom holland
on variety's actors on actors chatting
with their spider-man no way home
co-star andrew garfield the pair fully
dives into the spidey secrets behind the
blockbuster you know what we're talking
about the epic surprise they pulled off
tom andrew and og spiderman toby mcguire
all sharing one screen
it was just a really beautiful thing to
share together and to find a brotherhood
with toby as well and with tom but even
with all the excitement zee says the
spider-man icons being on set made tom
just a little shaky he was so nervous
and
because like you know he's like i don't
want to step on anyone's toes and i
don't want anybody to like
that me and toby were like that we were
like we don't want to step on
tom's like this is tom's movie it's your
guys movie and it was like if we can
help again just to serve and be absurd
but it's so funny because
he wouldn't he never let any he just
seemed so that's so sweet that you guys
were that's why we were there
so yeah cuz you guys were like i guess
we're gonna kind of hang out with you
guys
like what are these guys doing yeah
because the rehearsal we didn't really
have very many lines we're just like
we're there for emotions
we also learn more about this memorable
moment
[Applause]
are you okay
yeah
okay
are you okay
andrew's version of peter parker saving
zendaya's mj a nod to him not saving
gwen stacy aka emma stone in his final
spider-man flick i guess it was good to
get the more emotional stuff out of the
way because the rest of the time was
just just kidding
we were just having a good day
and get this they filmed it just hours
after they first met i loved shooting
that with you so much it was it wasn't
it wasn't like our first thing it was
like yeah absolutely and
i met you yesterday thanks for catching
me uh
how are you you good okay you have to
cry sorry it was pretty intense how's
that for an icebreaker it's crazy now we
gotta say seeing these two team up for a
chat has us craving more spider-man
collabs and it just might happen well if
andrew gets his way i would love to work
with toby i mean like he's such a great
actor in april he told et he's ready to
swing back into action with toby any
time he's a good buddy and i really just
love him i love spending time with him i
love him and i would love to to make
something with him for sure